bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté de
réagir en direct sur arte france alors
comme vous de nombreux étudiants en
soins infirmiers sont envoyés en
première ligne dans un contexte de crise
sanitaire exceptionnel comment vous
vivez cette arrivée brutale sur le
terrain finalement oui alors aujourd'hui
effectivement beaucoup d'étudiants sont
rappelés dans les services que soit en
stage ou en tant que professionnel
effectivement c'est c'est un nombre
énorme d'étudiants qui sont impliqués
directement
aujourd'hui ce qu'on remarque c'est
qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de violence
et c'est ce qu'on peut entendre dans les
médias depuis longtemps mais des
étudiants aujourd'hui sont pour la
plupart en souffrance parce qu'il n'ya
pas de sécurité qui est garanti et qui
ont néanmoins crucial de matériel est ce
que vous êtes vous êtes toujours
information est ce que vous vous sentez
vous et vos camarades suffisamment au
point opérationnel pour aider justement
les personnels soignants
alors oui effectivement nous on a des on
a des compétences qui sont qui sont
reconnus on est à la deuxième année on
peut travailler en tant qu'aide soignant
donc on peut dans tous les cas effectuer
des à des actes et les soignants pour
aider les le personnel soignant et les
équipes pour les décharger un petit peu
maintenant effectivement que ce soit
tant sur la santé mentale mais aussi au
niveau d'ondés des compétences même
aujourd'hui on n'est pas là dans tous
les cas pour venir remplacer un travail
d'infirmier chose qu'on peut aujourd'hui
demander dans les services et ça c'est
regrettable
est-ce que vous même vous êtes mobilisés
et racontez nous un peu votre expérience
sur le terrain
alors aujourd'hui la moins en ce qui me
concerne moi je suis du coup mobilisée
en tant que président de la fnesi de la
fédération nationale des étudiants en
soins infirmiers
je suis justement là pour assurer
l'accompagnement des étudiants parce qu
on est énormément mobiles mobilisées et
sollicité par des étudiants que ça par
téléphone par mail pour justement donc
soit les réorienter ou les accompagner
psychologiquement mais aussi leur
apporter de l'information sur leurs
droits
parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya un gros
manque de communication parce que
malheureusement tout est fait dans
l'urgence et quelles sont les
informations qui remontent vers vous est
ce que ces étudiants qui sont sollicités
sont bien accompagné alors justement
aujourd'hui on a un gros souci 1-2
d'accompagnement que ce soit tant sur le
volet psychologique mais aussi sur le
relais professionnels mais du couscous
qu'on marque aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a
on a beaucoup de de souffrance de
pression qui sont présentes un chez les
étudiants mais aussi donc un manque de
matériel des étudiants qui sont pour
certains mis en danger parce qu'ils ont
moins de matériel que les professionnels
à qui on dit mais il manque du matériel
pour les prix officiels il y en a déjà
pas assez pour l'équipe donc toi en tant
qu'étudiant tu en auras moins mais aussi
donc des primes de tenues par exemple
aujourd'hui les étudiants ils doivent
pour la plupart laver leurs tenues à
domicile chose qui va aujourd'hui en
fait ben en fait garantie ni après une
probable propagation du virus qui met en
danger la population aujourd'hui il ya
donc un risque un réel pour ces
étudiants qui sont mobilisés dans les
hôpitaux pour eux en tout cas ce risque
là vous vous le mesurer aujourd'hui on
est on est vraiment relation constante
avec avec tous les étudiants on essaye
au maximum de les accompagner au mieux
et d'interpeller les différents pouvoirs
publics qui sont que soient les régions
que soient les airs
que ce soit les ministères pour
justement mais faire en sorte
d'accompagner au mieux et que jean
sécurité qui sont garanties à ses
étudiants passent combien tout ça
l'urgence de cette crise sanitaire
sauf que malheureusement et bien et
c'est ce qui nous cause qui est
finalement de commissions c'est de
garantir la sécurité et de faire en
sorte qu'aucun étudiant ne soient mis en
danger ou mis en difficulté un symbole
fort dans sa formation parce que c'est
aussi le risque que derrière on ne
souhaite pas qu'ils aient des étudiants
qu'ils soient dégoûtés
ou en tout cas déçu de ce milieu
professionnel alors vous parlez des
pouvoirs publics
comment est-ce qu'ils vous soutiennent
ces pouvoirs publics alors aujourd'hui
on peut voir qu'on a déjà des des
ministères qui sont relativement à
l'écouté un autre problématique on à le
voir aussi des régions qui ont fait des
annonces concernant la valorisation de
l'indemnité des étudiants sans gagner
pour reconnaître leur engagement dans
les services
donc là on est à quatre régions qui ont
prédit des annonces dernièrement
maintenant ce qu'on demande aujourd'hui
c'est uniformisé cette valorisation là
parce qu'aujourd'hui parfaite les
étudiants sont impliqués partout sur
tous les territoires dans tous les
services alors tous les établissements
de santé et malheureusement cette
indemnité n'est pas à la même hauteur
partout sur le territoire
merci beaucoup félix ledoux d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le président de
la fédération nationale des étudiants en
soins infirmiers bon courage à vous
merci merci